ONE!
>> SVECHNIKOV RELOADS THROUGH
THE NEUTRAL ZONE OF HOFER.
TAKEN BY STEPAN.
CLAYTON GET TO IT
THAT PUCK IS HIT WITH A HAND.
SO E ST. LOUIS
ZONE.
JARVIS TAKEN OFF OF HIS SKATE,
AND A SCANDELLA OF GOALIE INTER
THERE'S NO
DOUBT.
IST FOR SETH JARVIS, BUT NOW
THE CANES HAVE OF
GETS IT AROUND TO AHO.
THOMAS TRIES TO GO ACROSS ICE,
TO THE A IN THE ST. LOUIS ZONE.
SVECHNIKOV, DEANGELO, BACK TO I
LOOK AT SEBASTIAN BACKCKRESULT
OF PERSON IT'S BEEN NOTICEABLE
TONIGHT. IS
GOING TO BE. AND
LYON MAKES .
IT MAYBE CLIPPED SLAVIN'S
STICK.
THAT'S A HECK OF A JOB OF
GOING TO HIT FOR THE
HURRICANES.
>> Mike: ST. LOUIS ONE FOR JAM
ALEX LYON WITH QUITE THE DEBUT
FOR
LAST NIGHT ON THE LORENTZ GOAL.
COULD MAKE THE
THOMAS NEAL, BUCHNEVICH, KYROU
CAN'T BELIEVE IT!
ALEX LYON WITH ANOTHER HUGE
SAVE!
>> Mike: FAULK THIS IS THE UN
BLUE ZONE, AND THAT'S GOING TO
BRING UP ICING AGAINST
CAROLINA.
>> Tripp: WENT
TO HIS BACKHAND.
THAT'S WHY SHOULD NOBODY STRANG
TO THAT, MADE 94 SAVES IN AN
AHL GAME.
>> Tripp: GOING TO PICK UP TH
PUCK FOR CAROLINA.
HE NEEDS TO A DANGEROUS CHANCE
PUCK RETRIEVAL.
THAT'S LOW.
PERRON,